- I had written into the
script this comic book guru.
In their world, it'd be like a Stan Lee.
And he's like, "Why don't you
just write it for Stan Lee?"
And I was like, "I don't know Stan Lee."
And he goes, "I do."
And I was like, "Hollywood is good."
Hey, man, I'm Kevin Smith.
- Jason Mewes!
- And we play Jay and.
- Silent Bob.
- He remembered.
- Yes!
(playful electronic music)
♪ My jungle love, yeah ♪
♪ Oh, we, oh, we, oh ♪
♪ I think I wanna know you, know you ♪
♪ Yeah, work it ♪
- I met Jason 32 years ago at this point?
We both grew up in the town
of Highlands in New Jersey.
And Jason was a figure
of a suburban legend.
So people would be like,
there's that Jay Mewes,
he broke the window at Cumberland Farms,
or there's that kid Jay Mewes,
I hear he fucked a dog once.
Which he didn't, right?
- [Jay] No, no, never.
- But everyone would say stuff about him.
He was a figure of mystery.
People knew him and stuff.
So one day, he came to my
house and my mom was like,
"That dirty boy from town is here."
And I was like, "Who?"
And I looked out and it was Jason,
and I was like, "Jason
Mewes is here, why?"
And I went out to answer the door.
I was like, "What are you doing here?"
And he goes, "What are we doing today?"
And so I kind of adopted him.
- I was drawn to him.
They would talk about comics and movies,
and they used big words, which
is funny now, but they did!
They used awesome--
- Me and my friends, we went outside!
But these guys, they sat inside
and talked about comic
books and big words!
- They did!
- We were the internet
before the internet.
- That was appealing.
That was appealing to me as a 13-year-old
'cause I'd be like, "What are they saying?
"They're saying things like ostentatious.
"What does that mean?
"That is magical!"
And they would talk about girls.
At 14, I had never even kissed a girl
and they actually had
a couple girlfriends,
a couple, but none.
At that age, they knew stuff.
So I wanted to hangout with
him as much as possible.
He had a room full of comic books
and he had tons of VHS
tapes and movies and stuff.
So I don't know.
That's what I remember about him.
Plus, I had seen him in--
- Sounds like I'm a pedo.
It's like, he had comics and movies,
and I was 13.
- And he had this secret room,
you pull it.
- And I was out in the woods
with my friends and he
said come hang out with us,
we've got big words for you.
It's a horrible story!
- He opened this room up
and there was a game
room, and candy and stuff.
I'm just kidding.
(both laughing)
And plus, he had a car and he drove us.
He would drive us to the
comic book store and stuff.
This is what I remember.
- Our friend's--
- I'd wanna hang out.
- I know!
He had a white-paneled
van with no windows,
he called it the Fun Buggy.
I don't remember it being fun,
but somehow we're friends.
There's a lot, I blacked out.
- There was a bed in the
back, I just remember that.
(both laughing)
Think of it as a 13-year-old,
that's what I remember.
It was super appealing.
All these things were appealing to me
because, again, I'd go out
and have fun with my friends
but I'd be like, oh, I
wonder what Kevin's doing.
I wanna go hangout with him
'cause he's gonna show
me "Full Metal Jacket"
and these movies.
To me, he had knowledge of
all movies and directors,
and they would talk about writers.
My parents would just be like,
"Hey, did you see the
new Van Damme movie?"
Which was, again, great,
but he would be like,
"Did you see the Van Damme movie?
"It was written by Joe Bob Billy Bob
"and directed by Scorsese."
Which never happened, but--
- What you're hearing here
is that I knew the credits of the movies
and because of that,
I was smarter than most
of the people you knew.
- It's true.
- So we became really good friends.
And I think he's
the most original human
being I've ever met,
hands down an American original.
Through most of our lives,
before I made the movie,
I would always be like,
"Man, you're funny,
"but I wonder if anyone
would find you funny
"outside of New Jersey.
"Somebody should put
you in a movie one day
"and find out if you're funny
"to people in Chicago
or something like that."
And then years later, when I was like,
ooh, I wanna make a movie,
one of the first things I thought
is I'm putting Jason Mewes in the movie
'cause he's the funniest person I know,
the most original person I know,
I wanna see if anyone else thinks
that snoogen stuff's worked.
So I'ma stick him outside
the convenience store
as one of the dealers.
I worked at a Quik Stop,
and you always had teenage weed dealers
hanging outside the building and stuff.
Never one of 'em.
There was always a group, or at least two,
one guy dealing, one guy
is his muscle and stuff.
And then I didn't wanna
give him somebody to talk to
because I wanted to showcase
all the stuff he says.
I'm like, he's way more interesting
when you just let him go.
So I was like, I'ma stick
somebody next to him,
a character who's his muscle,
but don't say anything.
There's a character in this movie I love
called "My Favorite Year".
Herb, one of the writers,
never spoke throughout the whole movie
and he would always kinda whisper
to one of the other writers.
In the midst of the
chaos of the third act,
at one point, they cut
to Herb and he goes,
"My god, this makes me happy."
And everyone stops and looks at him
'cause he hasn't said
anything the whole movie.
And then the movie just
goes back on and stuff.
So I liked that and I was like,
all right, man, I could
stick somebody next to Jay,
doesn't say anything,
and Jay's just talking
to him all the time,
and I went with the name Silent Bob
because I was a big fan of "Twin Peaks"
and Bob was one of the characters.
There was Mike and Bob that
lived above the grocery store,
above the convenience store.
So I went with Bob.
It just sounded kinda normal.
Also, Bob The Goon from "Batman",
Tim Burton 1989 "Batman",
he didn't really speak
throughout the movie and stuff.
So I had to pick a name,
and I went with Bob.
I couldn't name his
character anything but Jay.
It never occurred to me
to give him a fictional name
like Dirty Harry or whatever.
It's just like he was Jay and Jay was Jay.
So it became "Jay and Silent Bob".
- [Jason] Snoochie, boochie, noochies!
- Honestly, it started off as Neh.
Neh just started off as
meaning just kidding,
because at 13, 14,
I was always kidding with
my friends and/or people
and I wanted to make sure
they knew I was joking around with stuff.
- So he didn't get hit.
It began as Neh.
And it was almost like
this weird nervous tick.
The kid was always going
neh, neh, neh, neh, neh.
- [Jason] Yeah, totally. (laughs)
- And then it grew.
He started finessing it.
So he would be like,
noitch, and then, nooch.
Same thing, I slept with your mom, nooch.
He gotta threw a Dutch on it.
And then it would grow where he'd be like,
I slept with your mom last
night, snootchie bootchies,
and stuff like that.
It was amazing.
I watched language grow.
- I would do stuff for almost
for my own entertainment.
It was almost like a
nervous tick, like he said.
I would do things but I would
say it to entertain myself.
His good explanation is
the story in the library
when I busted in the library,
we kicked in the door,
and I didn't look at you
guys, and I was doing stuff.
- Now you gotta finish the story, man!
- Okay.
So he tells a good story
about he remembers,
and I remember this.
I would get bored--
- He walked in.
Me and Walt where at the Rec,
and we were bagging and
boarding our comic books.
All of a sudden, it was
quiet, no kids were there,
it was before the kids
came at three o'clock.
All of a sudden, the door,
boom, gets kicked open
and Jason Mewes marches
in and proceeds to fellate
anything somewhat phallic in the room.
So he grabs a pool stick
and he's sucking it off.
He grabs the phone and
he's sucking it off.
The flag pole, sucking the eagle off.
And me and Walter watched
him go from item to item
and he never looked at us.
It was never like, look at this, right?
It was almost as if like he
was walking around town, going,
oh, it's two o'clock,
I better go to the Rec
and suck everything off.
And so we sat there and watched him
and then he reached the Asteroids machine.
Asteroids, the kiosk, for
those that don't remember,
has no joystick.
There was nothing phallic for him to work.
And we were like, what's
gonna happen here,
as he stood there frozen
and then he shrugged and went (babbling)
on the roller ball, on the buttons.
So I was like, man, I wanna
hang out with this kid.
He's a genius and he's
very orally fixated,
so that's the kinda guy for me.
That's when I knew,
somebody should see this besides us.
He would work for an
audience of two or none.
It was like throwing away gold
where I'm like, this is legit funny.
So years later, after hanging
out for a couple years,
when I was like, I'm
gonna be a film maker,
I just remembered all the hits,
the greatest hits, and I was like,
I'm gonna have him do this,
I'm gonna have him do this.
And just to have him be an energy
and as a player in the movie
was something that I felt
like, yeah, it might work.
I just wanna see if anyone finds it funny.
And when it came out,
nobody talked about us.
Nobody was ever like,
"Jay and Silent Bob"!
There's one review that
mentioned Jay specifically.
They would mention me a lot
'cause they were like, in parentheses,
and the director also plays
a character named Silent Bob.
But they never talked
about "Jay and Silent Bob".
And then there was a review by,
I think it was Leah
Rosen in People magazine.
And she said, "Jason Mewes, you wanna find
"the rock he crawled out from under
"and make sure there's
nothing else like it
"under that rock."
And he showed me that review.
He's like, "Is this good?"
I was like, "That's a rave, man!
"That's huge!"
So we had no idea that there
was any sort of awareness
for the characters until "Mallrats".
The first time we did a
screening of "Mallrats"
at the San Diego Comic
Con 1995 at Horton Plaza,
that was a screening of about 200 people.
"Clerks" had gotten to home video,
but we hadn't thought about
that so all of a sudden,
Jay and Silent Bob come up on screen
and the audience erupted with recognition.
That blew me away where I'm like, what?
How?
And then I realized,
oh, because people have seen "Clerks" now
on home video and stuff.
So suddenly, we knew that
oh, people liked him.
- What is this shit?
Everyone's looking for us today.
We're ducking Trisha
'cause she wasn't to talk to Obi Wan here
about her video setup.
So I had to audition for Jay in "Mallrats"
and it was because the studio was like,
hey, we're giving you this much money.
And again, he probably can tell it better
because he was dealing with the producers
and the casting and all that.
- [Kevin] Jay had to play
Jay but the studio was like,
he's your friend, this is a funny role,
it could go to a real actor.
So they made us audition a bunch of people
and I still felt like he's the guy.
They had him audition against other Jays.
Seth Green was one of 'em.
- [Jason] Mark-Paul Gosselaar.
- He was like, I know
everybody sees me as Zach,
but what about Jay?
And we were like, huh.
But Seth Green, the studio
liked, and Breckin Meyer.
And Breckin went on to be
in "Clueless" and stuff.
So there were two guys
that they were like,
these are the two that
we want to play Jay.
We did a pizza playoff.
We had pizza and all the cast was there,
the studio got to see
all the different Jays,
the different Brodies, so forth and so on.
At the end of the day, he shined.
It was clear that he was the guy.
But at the same time, the studio was like,
here, we'll do this for you.
You can bring him out to Minnesota,
that's where we shot the flick.
We're not gonna fly him out,
we're not gonna put him up
for your month of rehearsal
so if you want him there, you
fly him out, you put him up.
And when we see his first day of dailies,
if we don't like him,
he's gone and we are
bringing in Seth Green.
So I said, okay.
We had a month to rehearse and stuff
and he got familiar and
comfy with everybody.
And the big thing was like
you have to be able to
act in front of people.
He couldn't do it on "Clerks".
On "Clerks", the dance scene
out in front of the store,
I was like, all right,
man, this is the scene,
all we do is dance.
Easy, no dialogue.
We just dance like we always do.
He's like, I can't dance in
front of all these people.
And it was literally
just the DP, Dave Kline, and
Scott Mosier, the producer.
So those dudes had to go into RST video
and hide behind the door,
and the camera was taped down
so it would just run
and record us and stuff.
At "Mallrats", it was more about
learn how to work in front of others
so you don't clam up and stuff like that.
And the first day, he was great.
I thought he was great.
We sent the dailies into the studio
and we were fingers crossed,
waiting to hear back from 'em.
They said, all right, he could stay,
and then they started paying
him from that day forward.
- Yeah.
- Oh my god!
Holy Shit!
Aren't you?
- Oh, Stan Lee, hi.
- I don't know.
Everyone calls it a
cameo but to me I'm like,
he was actually one of
the supporting characters.
He's in the movie quite a bit.
And he was in there because we loved him.
I had written into the
script this comic book guru.
Jim Jacks, the producer, was like,
"Hey, man, who is this supposed to be?"
And I said, "Well, I guess
it's kinda like in their world,
"it'd be like a Stan Lee."
And he's like, "Why don't you
just write it for Stan Lee?"
And I was like, "I don't know Stan Lee."
And he goes, "I do!"
And I was like, "Hollywood is good."
So Jim Jacks asked Stan
if he wanted to be in it
and Stan said yeah and we got to meet him
in Minnesota for the first time.
Me, Jason, and Walter was there with us.
We were beside ourselves
because this was Stan Lee.
At the time, comic book
people knew who he was
but outside of comic book people,
he wasn't insanely well-known.
10 years change later,
he would become the guy
that's the Where's Waldo
of the Marvel movies
and everybody would
know him the world over.
Your mom, your grandma would know
who Stan Lee was and stuff.
So in "Mallrats", we were able to be like,
for a new generation that maybe
wasn't familiar with comics
or who created or co-created
some of these great characters,
we were able to introduce him and be like,
hey, here's Spider-Man's
baby daddy and stuff.
Years later, when they made
the "Captain Marvel" movie,
Stan's on the train
and he's reading the
script for "Mallrats".
It says "Mallrats" by Kevin Smith.
And in that way, he kinda introduced me.
He returned the favor.
Years later, he introduced
me to a bunch of kids
who don't know who the hell I am
by way of that little
script cameo and stuff.
He was a friend, man.
He loved Jason.
His last cameo was in Jason's movie.
Very last, last thing he ever shot.
Wen Jason shot with him
that day, you can tell 'em.
- That I cried?
- Yeah.
So Stan, it was awesome.
Stan came down, I
directed my first feature.
- [Kevin] Called?
- Called "Madness in the Method".
I'm actually excited,
it's playing in Russia
in the next couple days.
- You're colluding?
- Yeah!
- Well done!
- Stan always jokes with Kevin
because Kevin put him in "Mallrats"
and Kevin's a director-writer.
And he's always like,
when are you gonna put
me in your next movie?
So I'm like, well, he
always tells Kevin he wants,
so maybe he would go on my movie.
So I was like,
"Do you think you would be
in a movie that I'm directing
"and that I'm gonna be part of?"
His guy was like, "Yeah, he'll come down.
"For two hours you can have him
"but he has to be home by six
"'cause he will not miss
dinner with his wife."
And I thought that was so sweet.
But he came down and it was super awesome.
We finally got the camera
ready and we started shooting
and we did three takes of the one thing.
We did a couple more after
but the first one, I said,
"Oh, can you do it again?
"Can you do this and say
something different?"
Then, I walked away and I
got a little teary-eyed.
So meeting Stan was awesome, first,
and then seeing him every time
and him saying hello to me was great,
and then for him to be in my movie.
So I had a moment and I stepped away.
I was like, (crying) this is so fantastic!
- [Producer] You dedicated this last film?
- Yeah, yeah, the reboot
we dedicated to Stan.
He was meant to be in it.
He was supposed to be
the guy in the third act.
He was the entire third act.
He was the dude that
was meant to be onstage
that our villains are after.
And of course, unfortunately, we lost him.
So we had this little piece
that we had shot on the IMDboat
during San Diego Comic Con
a couple years ago with Stan
where I was like,
"Hey man, let's do some
dialogue from the movie."
A little kind of audition thing.
And he was so wonderful in the clip.
He's not even putting on
the Stan Lee character,
he just starts cracking
up and just being himself,
and I loved the clip so
much that I was like,
"Let's end the movie with it."
'cause it was meant to be--
- I cried
when I watched that too. (laughs)
- Yeah, it's pretty great stuff.
He's right, hearing his
voice is like a time machine
and it just took you to
better times in your life,
or to moments, formative moments
with your friends and stuff.
(friends humming)
I remember after "Dogma",
we had a lot of famous people in "Dogma",
a lot of big actors and stuff.
Unlike "Clerks", all the reviews
talked about "Jay and Silent Bob".
And I'll never forget Matt Damon,
we did our New York Film
Festival premiere of "Dogma",
went on the stage at Alice
Tully, and during the Q and A,
Matt Damon was just like,
"Look, nobody's saying
it, but I'll say it."
He's going, "Jason Mewes
stole the movie out
"from under everybody on this stage."
and the whole crowd went nuts
and applauded and stuff like that.
So we went through a lot of
hell, pun intended, on "Dogma"
with some religious cats and
there were death threats.
So after that, I was like,
well, the next movie,
I'm gonna make something that's just fun,
and hopefully we don't get death threats,
something that nobody
could be offended by.
And since they played so well in "Dogma",
and also, I should give a
little bit of a shout out
to Wes Craven as well.
After "Dogma", we did this
tiny piece in "Scream 3"
'cause that's where I met Wes,
where "Jay and Silent Bob"
popped up in "Scream 3".
And we did the Connie Chung bit.
It was at the same lot we'd
eventually shoot "Strike Back".
It was CBS Radford.
We were there for a day and
I remember being on the lot
and being like, this would be fun, man,
to be on an actual movie studio lot
and shoot a movie and stuff,
and "Jay and Silent Bob", and
Hollywood, that's kinda funny.
So it all coalesced and
came together and I said,
you know what?
Let's do a movie that's like you and me.
We'll be the leads this time around,
Jay and Silent Bob adventure.
He was all for it by that point.
He wasn't against it at all.
But there were drugs back then as well.
That was the difficulty, man.
Getting him clean used to be problem
because he fell into heroin
and Oxycontin and stuff like that.
Getting ready for "Dogma"
was a Herculean effort,
and then getting ready for "Jay
and Silent Bob Strike Back"
was the same thing.
It was about keeping him away from drugs,
rehabbing him at the
house, and stuff like that.
"Jay and Silent Bob" might be the reason
he's still above ground 'cause
it was always this kind of,
well, you gotta get clean,
man, or else we don't do this.
So it'd be something you could use
to keep him on the straight and narrow.
But then, the movie would end
and you couldn't stop him.
"Jay and Silent Bob Strike
Back", he was clean throughout,
no drugs, but he drank.
You can see he's got
some kinda booze bloat
in his face in the movie.
I remember at one point,
the guy in charge of Dimension called up,
he said he saw the dailies and said,
"Hey man, should we get Jay a trainer?"
And I was like, "Why?"
And he's going,
"There's a shot where you guys
"are hanging over the camera in a huddle,"
and he's going,
"And he's got a bigger
turkey neck than you."
And I was like, "He's
trying to be off drugs!
"Don't tell him he's gotta
lose weight as well!"
So he, on "Strike Back",
the moment we stopped shooting in Jersey,
the moment we wrapped,
boom, he fell back down
into the drug hole again.
So that was always kinda difficult,
and probably one of the main reasons
why we didn't do more "Jay
and Silent Bob" stuff.
- It's hard for me to watch my performance
in any of the movies drugs
or not drugs, honestly,
because I always feel like I watch myself
and I'm like, oh, I
could've been funnier here,
I should've gave this look,
I should've done that.
With or without drugs,
I don't really feel.
But again, of course,
I know there was like,
oh, wow, that day I was in the
bathroom every five minutes
and I kept saying, oh, my stomach hurts.
So I remember these bad moments.
But it was always tough.
I don't know why towards the end,
it'd almost be like,
it's almost over and I'm
celebrating now but--
- 'Cause you were an addict.
You're just like, I just
gotta get through this
and then I can get back to
doing what I really wanna do.
- Jay, brace yourself.
You're about to meet our lovechild.
- I think I'm gonna need
to see a blood test.
- It's almost 10 years now
that you've been clean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And the big difference maker,
at first it was the podcast,
we did "Jay and Silent Bob Get Old",
but then he had a kid, he had Logan.
That was everything.
Suddenly all his priorities
snapped into place.
This would be the dude you'd joke about.
He wouldn't be in charge of a dozen eggs,
let alone another human being,
let alone a small human being,
but he turned out to be like super dad.
Hands down, the best dad
I've ever seen in my life,
and I include myself as
a dad in that equation,
and even my father.
I don't know if its because,
it's because he's got a
million-dollar heart probably,
but something to do with his
upbringing made him super dad
because he didn't know
his dad or whatever.
He's not even overcompensating,
he's just doing it the way
it's supposed to be done.
I almost wish he had a kid long before me,
'cause I would've been like,
oh, that's how you do it.
And that's kind of where reboot came from.
We'd be talking about it on tour.
He's always like,
"When are we gonna make
another Jay and Bob movie?"
I'm like, "Never.
"We did it once and that was it."
But then I would use it too.
I was like, "If you stay sober,
"maybe we will make another
"Jay and Silent Bob" movie."
And then one day, it came to it,
and then the story kinda wrote itself
because he was a dad in real life.
It was so amusing to see
him be this incredible dad.
He relates to the kid like I've never seen
an adult relate to their own child.
It might be because even
though he's 45 and she's four,
they're emotionally on the
same level or whatever,
but it's a really warm,
wonderful relationship.
And I was like, I'm gonna
do that for the movie.
So I stole his real life
and put it in the flick.
- What I loved is that over the years,
he's adapted our characters
based on where him and I are.
"Clerks II" is I just got out of rehab,
and the Holy Bible song
and all that stuff.
And it's because I literally
had just gotten out of six months rehab,
and I had some time clean.
"Clerks" always super obnoxious
and you could see it, like I'm young,
like, I'll F anything that
moves and all this stuff.
And then "Mallrats",
I'm a little bit goofier,
snootchie bootchies.
I feel like it's always
grown a little bit with that.
Again, it's perfect.
I think this movie,
honestly, is super clever
and I aint just saying
this 'cause he's here.
But I feel like he's super clever
in how he ties in all the other movies,
how he's brought it to where
because I'm a dad in real life
and how I've been sober for a while
and I'm married for a while,
and Jay and Bob are grown
up and it's "My Two Dads",
and then his daughters in the film.
It's just taking all this stuff.
- You just gave my secret sauce.
It was "My Two Dads".
We literally stole this
movie from "My Two Dads".
(both laughing)
- Ladies, Ladies, Ladies,
Jay and Silent Bob are in the Hizzles!
You ever had your asshole licked
by a fat man in an overcoat?
(Kevin laughs)
Yo, baby, you ever have
your asshole licked
by a fat man in an overcoat?
Yeah!
- The entire series, that's
the highlight for you?
- It's one of 'em, yeah.
On the screen, but meeting
Stan, if we're going back,
that is one of my favorite in "Mallrats".
But that's my favorite.
- Your character never met Stan.
- No, I know.
That's why I'm saying my character,
this is my favorite moment.
- Still!
All those movies, it comes down to this?
That would irritate me
when people would talk about "Clerks",
like, oh, my favorite part
is when you guys dance in the dark.
And I'm like, nobody says anything!
That movie's all about dialogue!
It was always like a weird
backhanded compliment.
My favorite moment in any
of the movies hands down
belongs to him and Harley.
They have this kind of quasi
breakup moment in the movie
where they have to go their separate ways.
And the two of 'em were
absolutely dazzling.
I cry every time I watch it,
and I honestly believed
for those few seconds
that they're not the two people I know.
They transcend with their performance,
and I forget she's my kid
and I forget he's him,
and I go like, these poor people,
if they could just get
their shit together.
She needs a dad, he needs a daughter.
Oh, it makes me upset even now.
Not upset, but like happy tears.
And it was him and her.
They blew the doors off that moment.
And of everything I've ever
done, that stands out for me.
(upbeat drum music)